I see I see fat models all the time but  so look at lizard but men aren't looking  at yeah so this was only lizard that's  it but there's always out there is there  but I'm saying it's catered it's catered  to women like Victoria's Secret they're  bringing in fat chicks this is supposed  to be the epitome of beauty they're  bringing in fat chicks that's because  like other brands have understood that  the world is universal not everyone is  tall and skinny and I accept that  Victoria's Secret didn't that's why now  they're trying to jump on the bandwagon  but they're doing it for their customers  yeah they're catering to women that's  what I'm saying like everything's about  women yeah